an alleged isis-linked male in the u.s
was plotting to kill george w bush going
so far as to travel to dallas in
november to take video around the former
president's home and recruiting help
from a team of compatriots he hoped to
smuggle into the country over the
mexican border according to an fbi
search warrant application filed on
march 23rd
the fbi said it uncovered the scheme
through the work of two confidential
informants and surveillance of the
alleged plotters account on the
meta-owned whatsapp messaging platform
[Music]
the alleged isis operative based out of
columbus ohio said he wanted to
assassinate bush because he felt the
former president was responsible for
killing many iraqis and breaking apart
the country after the u.s invaded the
country in 2003 according to the warrant
bush a republican who was in the news
last week when he inadvertently referred
to the u.s invasion of iraq in a speech
about the russian invasion of ukraine
was president from 2001 to 2009.
the case shows how federal investigators
continue to monitor threats from isis
even as the group has been severely
weakened by american intelligence and
military operations in recent years
it also shows how the fbi despite its
claims of being prevented from
investigating major crimes because of
meta and other tech providers use of
encryptions has been able to work around
whatsapp security by using old-school
policing with sourcing from informants
and tracking the metadata they can get
from the messaging company
the alleged plot organizer has been in
the u.s since 2020 and had an asylum
application pending according to the
fbi's search warrant application
in november 2021 the suspect revealed to
the fbi's insider the plot to
assassinate bush and asked the
confidential source if he knew how to
quote obtain replica or fraudulent
police and or fbi identifications and
badges to help carry out the killing and
whether or not it was possible to
smuggle the plotters out of the country
the same way they came in after the
mission was complete according to the
warrant
as many as seven members of the group
would be sent to the u.s to kill
president bush according to a
conversation described in the warrant
his plan according to the warrant was to
get the isis operative's mexican visitor
visas using passport information he
would send the informant over whatsapp
before getting them over the border
the alleged smuggler said he also wanted
to find and assassinate a former iraqi
general who helped americans during the
war and whom he believed was living
under fictitious identity in the u.s
investigators said
as part of its surveillance of the
alleged plotters the fbi recently
received permission to acquire mobile
location information from at t
it had already used what's known as a
pen register on the whatsapp account
believed to belong to the chief suspect
helping them determine how often the
account was used what numbers it was
contacting and whether or not it was
active
while the suspect seemed convinced his
whatsapp account was secure he was
unaware that investigators could see
every message he sent to confidential
sources nor was he aware that starting
in october he was using a phone that he
was given by the informant at the fbi's
request the informant noted that the
target was a keen user of whatsapp and
was a member of bath isis chat groups in
the app
while the sources were passing on what
they learned over whatsapp throughout
2021 and 2022 they were also secretly
recording the in-person meetings with
the alleged plotter in which additional
startling details were revealed
according to the fbi
in one conversation from december
according to the warrant the suspect
claimed to have had just smuggled two
individuals associated with hezbollah a
terrorist organization according to the
us into the u.s for a fee of 50 000 each
as no charges have yet been filed
against the suspect forbes is publishing
neither his name nor the full warrant
it's unclear if he has been arrested
neither the department of justice nor
bush's office responded to requests for
comment at the time of publication
[Music]
you